going into round six of the 2014 sink
field cup it's been all mr perfect
fabiano carolina not only has fabiano
won every game of the five he played so
far but he's also moved his ranking
sadly to number two in day one fabiano
versus vessel and topolov carano with a
convincing win in day two the frenchman
mvl falls to the careful plans of mr
perfect in day three the much
anticipated matchup with the world's
number one magnus carlsen and don
fabiano handles the pressure and gains
his third point in day four there are no
free passes in the sink field cup and
carolina now faces a formidable lavon
oroneon and again gains the victory
day five fabiano faces his nemesis
hikaru nakamura who he has had trouble
with in the past but not on this day not
during this crazy run
day six there's just one question can mr
perfect do it one more time our coverage
starts right now
hello and welcome to day six of the sink
field cup thanks for joining us after
taking a rest day yesterday for labor
day here in st louis but that hasn't
kept the world from buzzing about
fabiano caruana who has made history
winning the first five rounds of the
tournament and so he's picked up a few
nicknames along the way like mr perfect
the godfather of chess don fabiano and
even the italian stallion so let's send
it down to the studio with jen yasser
and maurice to get all the action
started
that's right we missed you guys and
maybe some of you missed us as well we
are back for the second half of the 2014
sink field cup
can flaviano repeat what he did in the
first half and go tenno we're gonna find
out starting today we see the players
not yet arrived still resting yeah
they're getting ready for the big
matches i'm jennifer shahadi and i'm
here with grand master yasser sarwan and
just like in the first half we're going
to be here with you every day covering
what was absolutely thrilling action
yeah the first half of the event was
amazing to watch truly historic and of
course fabiano has been incandescent
in this tournament and it's just amazing
to witness what he's done it is and can
he continue it so for those of you who
haven't been living under a rock let's
take a look at the standings who's who's
on top
fabiano faviano of course he's got five
out of five
perfect score vessel and topalov and
magnus
or world champion magnus on an even
score after a nice victory going into
the rest day over iranian meanwhile
maxine bashir lagrave
alone and fourth with two points and
tied for last but two very combative
players in karo nakamura and lavon
oronion trying to get out of the
basement today
and the matchups
nakamura and ironia do play each other
so
we're going to see how that goes and
which one of them can climb out caruana
versus topala
piranha playing white magnus carlsen
versus mbl
so maurice what do you think we're going
to see today at the sink field cup as we
begin our second half
well welcome to round six of the caruana
cup it's been all fabiano caruana and
all eyes are on him again today in his
matchup against vesseling topolov a
former world champion himself the
youngest player in the competition
versus the veteran of play well this
game should be hot should be heavy these
two have fought before caruana with a
slim advantage no respect for his elders
this kid 2-1 lead in their classical
match-ups but fabiano playing so well
he's mr perfect fabulous fabiano when
asked what he prefers to be called he
says his friends who know him call him
fabi while fabi is in control of this
tournament he has the players by the
throat all of them staring at him in
wonder at the play he's been displaying
as you say yes incandescent the
superlatives are incredible when you
start talking about this kid number two
in the world now firmly at 28 20
in his rating he's surging high closing
in on magnus carlson himself which was
just
unbelievable to imagine before the
tournament started so we expect more
great play from him here in round six of
the sink field cup guys
that's right maurice mentions fabiano
closing in on magnus carlsen
28-21 still
almost 40 points to go
yeah but before the gap was so much
bigger i mean it was closer to 80
points so that's right and i like some
of those uh fabulous nicknames fabiano's
so
modest in fact i think now he holds the
record
somebody uh out there let me know if you
can contest this but he's got to hold
the record for
the highest rated
player in history to give a draw in an
exhibition game
usually players who are that good right
don't do that right you're referring to
the bronx that's right yesterday it was
so much fun wasn't it yes yesterday we
played burning boards and actually the
chess players so yasser and i play
maurice played
all the players all of the players in
the singapore cup played as well as some
other grand masters and chess luminaries
in town they all played against artists
right so the deck was stacked in our
favor of course yes and there was wax
all over the boards and the artist
didn't know where the pieces were a lot
of the time so we were helping them and
everything and fabio went even beyond
hello thing and somehow the game ended
in this skill mate right he composed a
stalemate it was very nice i don't know
how the players realized it was a
stalemate at the end of the game well he
of course knew what what each piece was
and he was like oh it's a stomach
next to me
was uh magnus and he was playing against
glenn
who uh
the creator of the entire show
and it was really funny because at the
end
all the players are entered at the end
of the game uh um magnus needed to
deliver a mate on the c8 square but the
c8 square was in a pool of wax so he had
to use his tongs to chisel away the wax
from the ca square it was really
wonderful it is and we're going to be
seeing some footage as well as an
interview with the glenn himself later
in the broadcast so we do see
magnus scarlesson um versus mvl today
what do you have in terms of uh
predictions for openings fabiano
carolina playing with the white pieces
against topalov i'm interested to see if
we
get a super sharp sicilian because these
two have combated in that i mean their
games have been really thrilling so i am
expecting a sicilian in fact and by the
way oh fabiano is on a great great
winning streak it has to be mentioned
that vessel
former world champion vessel and topalov
started with two losses he's climbed
back to even score and he's playing
he's playing very well so this might be
fabiana's biggest test so far in the
tournament
playing against an opponent former world
champion been there done that he knows
what it takes
to win with black and
he's
he's primed and ready to go
that's right
one of the headlines from chess 24
earlier in the event was caruana hot
topple of knot
but now we can say they're both they're
both kind of well one of them is burning
and the other one is warm
off warming up heating up and the
players
just shook the hands as our leader
of the sinkville and let's take a seat
for it i'm actually we were referring to
this game yesterday when well two days
ago when topalov was on the white side
of a sicilian and won this really nice
strategic game we were saying that
sometimes the sicilian is not all about
checkmating sometimes it's about
positional play and just
you know out uh out maneuvering your
opponent which is what precisely what he
did in that game
yeah kind of a combination of both in a
way that he was kind of creeping in on
the king's side yes but in this game
tavalav also an expert in that same
opening with the black pieces the
sicilian night orc his mainstay for many
years he likes sharp
uh
tactical uh
openings and the sicilian suits his
suits him perfectly yes and these two
actually played in norway chess in a
sicilian defense as dave and england
that game was a draw
but every battle between these two just
seems to be so exciting and hard-fought
yes that's right um and then there was
also another sicilian in which caruana
won a brilliant game and that was a
little while ago that was in 2013.
so
i mean i'm no sorry the topology in 2013
yes exactly
now the other game
naidor the other game uh also although
both players as you say are in the
basement hikaru nakamura and the
bonaroni in lavon is going through
a bad patch he has lost three on a trot
after a fairly
modest
fortunate start lavon ironian started
with one and a half out of two and he's
seen his fortunes go backwards hikaru
nakamura
also having an awkward event
he had
he's had better chances than his score
reflects and he's looking to try to
increase the pressure on levo neroni and
that's right having lost three
karu to make a move
let's say two seconds to show his st
louis fans something there he's got his
red bull is he going to get fired up you
know right before when we saw the first
battle between these two in the
springfield cup we made a lot of how
ironian just been crushing nakamura
lately in fact ever since last year's
sing field cup lavon has won
four different with white in four
different ways i mean it's just been
been dazzling and nakamura had a
comfortable draw against him in this
event in the first half that that's
exactly right so now he gets a crack
with white mm-hmm and he even lost a
game with white recently to levan and
taught us steel in 2013. right so that
was before the singapore cup but
so he's a worried
hikaru is
well aware that he's playing an
extremely dangerous opponent for himself
that's right and
on the other hand he's saying
i'm never going to have such a good
chance
of getting a point back as i am today
lavone's reeling three losses in a row
i've got white
and everything to play for
that's right
and then meanwhile of course we can't
forget our world champion
magnus carlson playing against mbl what
are you expecting in that game
that's
much harder to predict uh magnus played
e4 against fabian and cariowana came out
with the bishop's opening really showed
he wasn't looking for an advantage with
white against fabiano um he got a poor
game and didn't do much and ended up
losing in fact so
maybe today
think that's a good prediction actually
yeah because he just got so little in
that game yeah i mean less than nothing
and left a very sour taste
after the result as well and of course
mvo being very well prepared but
yesterday even being well prepared
something going a little bit wrong when
he got that sicilian najdorf and
you know you just didn't find quite
enough counter play and topalov won a
great strategic game so the players have
actually made some opening moves that
would be you know and we have a sicilian
caruana vs topalov
very exciting you know it looks like
fabiano's playing the open line of the
sicilian right we've seen a large number
of open sicilians in this tournament
which goes to show what kind of uh
competitive uh
spirits are are floating around here at
the st louis chess club as the players
are essaying some of the sharpest
variations
actually we have another sicilian magnus
carlson it looks like he's played a
close sicilian effort right you got that
right becoming a little bit more popular
as of late
these close sicilian type systems which
uh
you know kind of make it less of an e4
battle a little bit more like a d4
battle and that the game is more
prolonged and the attacks are a little
bit slower but also a lot of fun oh
definitely uh the
world champion former world champion
vasily smithslav loved to play the close
sicilian and avoid a lot of the sharp
lines and going into those positional
channels right and keeping it closed
because one of the things that sicilian
players like is they like that
little bit of openness the semi-open
game the open c file
and it can be a little bit trickier to
play the closed sicilian systems for
black
um especially if it's if it's like not
what you've been preparing for as much
of course at this level mbo will be very
well prepared but i noticed a lot at
other levels people spend so much of
their study time on their open sicilians
and then the closest thing they just
give a cursory glance to
and that results sometimes in some very
poor results exactly if you're not
prepared
your opponent trots out the closest
alien you're not well prepared it's very
easy to get a poor game in the first
half of the tournament by the way jen
you were saying to me what are the odds
that we don't see of berlin and i
thought
we would and we have and we have
a berlin yeah kind of like an
anti-berlin right it's not the ending uh
variation so hikaru nakamura
uh playing against levon aronian
has played
knight takes e4 berlin rookie one the
move that we
the ending rather that we were all
referring to is
that appears on the board is this one
which has become very topical at the
highest levels of chess
um oops my monitor just kind of
disappeared there
and we'll have to go to maurice yeah
we'll get you right back up don't worry
um meanwhile we see the games beginning
and
grandmaster maurice ashley might have
some thoughts for us on how these
openings are shaping up
well i wanted to mention jen this game
between fabiano caruana and vaseline
topolov
the games between them have always been
interesting fights but also interesting
is the fact that black has won every
single decisive game that's clearly
unusual black winning every game that's
a decisive game it's only been three
decisive ones but every time black has
had the edge and they'll take one game
for example to paulov last year in suga
in the fide grand prix he got this
position out of a night or sicilian
another sicilian very sharp game and he
ended up getting these fantastic pawns
going down the board and in this
position he was definitely with edge
after king d1 he played g4 sacrificing a
pawn so he could play f4 chasing the
knight out of the middle of the board
now the knight had to go and then this
move bishop c7 guarding a critical pawn
and there was nothing that karwana could
do about this advance of this f pawn
going down the board the knight came
back and then this move bishop to e3 and
suddenly the pawns were just going to
roll down the board this one to e4 this
one in e3 and crush
crush white karana resigned in this
position so he knows full well that
tapalov is a dangerous opponent as you
mentioned he has surging now in the
competition is to paul of something
about tapa that's really interesting
when you ask him you know you're playing
really well right now how do you feel
he
takes the road listen
i don't care about the result i'm just
trying to play good moves i'll see what
happens next that's a dangerous opponent
to have to face someone who's just
trying to play chess and see what
happens so karana is well aware that
he's up against it with this opponent
guys and he's well aware that he's going
to get a very exciting game indeed um
how these moves appeared already on the
board yes they have the players look at
where we are yeah fabiano and uh veselan
have been zip
zipping right along
uh we have a time enough sicilian
knight c6 not the night not the night of
that
vessel and likes so very much
and a very topical variation indeed
has appeared on the board
rookie one all of these moves have been
played before knight d7 queen g4
coming
down after the spawn on g7 trying to
provoke uh trying to create some type of
weakness on the king side for example is
no good castling is no good it walks
into the standard bishop h6 threatening
checkmate on g7 and that would cost
black material so you have a savory
choice between g6 and king f8 right
all right so yeah we're going to take a
more detailed look at the opening in
just a minute but for now
as we get our boards reset up
we'll
we'll just point out that the openings
today we did again an exciting sicilian
in fabiano carrana's game against vessel
and topolove we've got another sicilian
shaping up in carlson maxine bashir
lagrave it started within knight c3 and
then it came back it transposed into an
open sicilian into an open sicilian and
not only that a dragon variation i'm in
heaven
an accelerated dragon i'm absolutely in
heaven yes sir the three openings today
all wide open struggles um the one game
that surprised me a little bit hikaru
nakamura's line against lavon oronion
perhaps he has something prepared
because
this particular variation not thought to
give white a whole lot exactly the
position is
so even in terms of the pawn structure
such as symmetrical structure
very very hard indeed for white
to achieve much of an opening advantage
but normally he does get the two bishops
in this line so maybe akaru is satisfied
with a small very small plus yeah but
that kind of makes you wonder why not
play d4 or c4 if you're gonna like to me
because nakamura is always prepared for
those lines
i would wonder what he has up his sleeve
because if he doesn't think that he can
get anything serious against a berlin
why not just play his other mainstay
yeah
all right and
boy the players are really moving like
right along i mean
we do have uh oh they're kind of fired
up
yeah yesterday's battles remember we had
the burning boards yesterday exactly and
that was a blast absolutely so much fun
the fire marshal did ask me
to maybe pull back my hair a little bit
she was a little worried my hair was
going to set on fire
no emergency hair appointments right
and how did you do against your artist
you told us that fabiano gave up a draw
were you as generous not quite as
generous but what did happen was i i was
about to set up this this pretty
checkmate the king was on the king was
on e6 and i checked the king and then
king takes d6 and i had a bishop on g5
so i had like a queen e7 mate right it
was very pretty there so it was a pretty
final mate and alejandro is watching and
he says something funny
and i laugh and as i'm making the mate
my i laugh so hard that my king blows
out oh you extinguished your own king so
you lost but it's checkmate on the board
i think international arbiter chris byrd
would say that i want okay
it was a little bit in question but the
great thing about this piece i've
actually participated in this burning
boards exhibition by glenn kyno in
new york and in san diego is a little
different every time
and of course
what was awesome to see this year was
that all six players played well exactly
i mean glenn couldn't have asked for a
better group of participants all of the
participants of syncfill cup and the
reigning world champion magnus carlson
as well how sweet indeed it was really
it was really fun and it's it's great to
hear glenn talk about art and he's
actually going to be with uh maurice in
just a bit but the world chess hall of
fame constantly bringing in artists to
you know kind of show people who don't
love chess yet
why they should exactly they might think
that it's too difficult that's the line
i get all the time and i'm not smart
enough for it i hate that line because i
know so many dumb chess players oh
i'm shocked shocked
jennifer no no i mean
it's a blessing and a curse obviously
it's great to be seen as as smart but we
don't want people to think that it's too
difficult for them if they don't have a
genius iq or something absolutely yes
for sure and let's see and our board is
back let's get back into the game
and let me go uh once again
through the opening moves i'll slow it
down a little bit e7 e6 this last move
by black um
uh is a star towards a time enough or a
paulson variation the favorite move on
move two by vessel and topalov is d7 d6
just to go for the night or straight
into the belly's beats like yesterday's
game exactly where mbl did play the
night or e6 was however vesselen's
choice keeping a kg d4 takes knight c6
knight c3 a7a6 this system was developed
by mark taimanov a grand master from the
old soviet union days and he made it
very popular hence it bears his name and
i always find it to be a little tricky
to play these lines with white because
sometimes it's fun but somehow the play
is a little bit less clear because you
don't know exactly what black's going to
do with their pawns so exactly and
there's a lot of little transpositional
tricks like if they play queen c7 and
not a6
so
it can be a good line i think for black
to to play just because a lot of times
white is so much more prepared for the
night or from the dragon and those lines
which are a little bit more linear
and so this one
a little tricky exactly and like you say
black has some flexibility he can play
d6 d4 e5 at times d6 c5 however vessel
went directly
into the main
lines with d7 d5
castles now of course from a positional
point of view black's gotten a lot of
things that he doesn't always get in the
sicilian he has control of the b file he
has control of d5 he got to move d5 in
so why is he not just doing really
really well well of course in order to
get you must give and he's given up a
lot of development exactly he's got this
beautiful pawn center so the center is
not
nice and blocked and he's hoping that
in the future black is hoping in the
future that the that his extra control
of the center will
lead
to an advantage for him however just as
you mentioned white has an edge in
development and white is looking to get
an
attack on the king side
knight f6 now this is actually a moment
where black can be a little bit cageyer
he could play for set up with bishop d6
and knight e7 and not allow this
immediate center punch with e4 e5
which we are about to see right now
driving the night away
and this move queen g4 heralds
a direct attack on the king side by
white as he's threatening the pawn on g7
vessel and played the move king f8
giving up
his castling privileges so definitely
white gets something in return for
having given up the center he's
compromised black's king a bit
as we were leaving
before we were mentioning pardon me that
he castles
the highly desirable move castles just
walks into bishop h6 which wins material
this one's in exchange and the move g7
g6 on the other hand
uh allows
white to infiltrate on the dark squares
now that the pawn has been forced to
advance to g6 so king f8
everything goes okay
and after this move king f8 we can see
that black has a little bit of a cramped
pieces on the queen side and what black
would like to do is play knight
f
knight d7 to c5 and eliminate this
bishop on d3 hence we see this move
knight a4
as well the move knight a4 liberates the
c pawn so that you can play c2 c4
attacking black in the center queen a5
don't forget
there's a rook on pre over here
rookie two just getting out of that uh
immediate attack and now
it's a topology so let's uh move to
another pretty intriguing opening magnus
carlson playing against maxine bashir
the grave and
this is a surprising opening we wouldn't
have expected this before the game so we
were just talking about how on the
second move
instead of going for the mainline
sicilians magnus instead played knight
c3 but the tricky thing about knight c3
is that
usually when the game starts that way it
will lead to a close sicilian or a grand
prix type position but
it's not a hundred percent white could
change his mind and play knight f3 and
d4 so black has to make sure that
they're prepared for that for instance
if you like playing g6s
against uh closed sicilians
and you play and you play g6 after
knight c3 well all of a sudden white
might switch back to an open sicilian
and play d4 so you got to make sure that
you got your opening repertoire set for
this type of move knight c3 so instead
knight f3 in this position and magnus
did precisely that so he decided hey i'm
switching back if black really really
wanted to avoid an open line sicilian he
could play e5 here right um and which
has been seen on numerous occasions
that's why bobby fischer in his 1992
rematch versus boris baskey actually
played the move knight e2 the idea as
you're saying is to play d4 open
sicilian and in case of e5 bobby's idea
was to play knight
d5 and the other knight to c3
immediately occupying the d5 square that
wasn't what magnus did he played knight
f3
after g6
we got
an accelerated dragon bishop c4
now if white if black wants he can play
d7 d6 that will transpose into a regular
drive the mainline dragon yes would
really blow our minds today we would
have a hard time keeping our eyes off
this game so instead um the
accelerated dragon and that will also be
very sharp and you gotta wonder how well
magnus carlsen is prepared for this
particular line he might have expected
something different so yes will be
really interesting to follow this now
meanwhile we've been talking a little
bit about burning boars which happened
yesterday in the rest day of course
magnus carlson and maxine vasyar legrov
both played in it in fact mvo actually
played a really good game
yes yeah and it's actually published on
chess.com so i recommend you guys to
head on over there and check that game
out um mike klein called it the immortal
wax game
and uh we have the
creator of burning boards glenn keinel
and he's with the curator larry list
curator and author and the cool thing
about both of them is that
they have both been to all three burning
boards exhibitions of course glenn
created it and originally it was in the
whitney museum and then they had a
rendition in san diego and then of
course
how can you beat glenn got a chance to
play magnus carlson i think that was why
he created this artistic event that
eventually he would never everybody
would get to play the world championship
except when he created it magnus was
like eight
he he he anticipated he was thinking
ahead yes and here they are and they're
with maurice ashley to talk a little bit
about merging chess and art
thanks glenn i am with glenn keino and
larry list guys welcome to the show
thank you very much thanks so glenn you
created this work of art it's now been
displayed in two places
how was yesterday's show different from
the other two well as i said yesterday
when i imagined the work i could not
imagine in my wildest dreams the caliber
of players um
who participated yesterday so i was very
thankful to have that it was it was
beyond expectation it was unreal you had
six of the top ten players in the world
playing yeah you got to play and
jennifer you got to play against magnus
carlson himself absolutely did you take
it easy on him uh well i i you know i
didn't really have you know i practiced
uh playing magnus with magnus because i
downloaded his app
which is amazing and i played magnus age
five
six seven uh and he started to give me
problems when he was at seven so um
but what i thought i would do is since i
didn't really have a strategy i i i when
i play uh these games i wanted to make
sure that i don't lose in the first two
minutes so what i tried to do was mirror
him
in the beginning until i figured that
the only thing he wouldn't know about my
strategy is when i was going to stop
mirroring him and so we mirrored for a
few moves
and then actually it was it was amazing
he was so generous the first move that
uh i will tip that the first move that i
was going to do that was a non-mirrored
move i was about to move it and he
looked at me
and he just got to get me out of the and
so we played a little bit and
and then you know probably after my
second move uh he had the whole game
mapped out and i lost uh very graciously
and it was it was very fun well
get used to it a lot of people lose yeah
i was joining joining the club that's
right
larry
you've been a curator for years a writer
what what is your opinion of this this
magnificent idea
of uh of glands well
fortunately both jen and i have had the
the opportunity to participate in both
of the other two performances and i
think we both thought as soon as the
hall of fame was coming into being that
the perfect place the center of the
country and the center of the chess
world the perfect place for glenn's
performance would be here
and fortunately sort of we were able to
work this out and uh we were so
fortunate in having like great people
sort of participate
and a great audience as well and so
uh
it was kind of uh i think you and i
talked last night i was going to try and
describe it as sort of like
okay incredible spontaneity sort of
desperate moves frustration inspiration
boards going up in flames and i said
well wait is that the burning boards or
is it the first five rounds of the
sinfield couple
because it's been such sensational play
indeed it's been fantastic uh glenn you
had a great quote you shared uh last
night that i just love so much a high
degree quote why don't you share that
and the inspiration you have when you
when you had this idea yeah the quote
was that the uh possible ranks higher
than the actual um
and to me you know for for me when i was
thinking when i think about chess i
think that it's a it's a it's a ballet i
was saying that happens in the imaginary
in the future under multiple lines
and there's so much
work that that you as chess players do
to rethink the world and rethink
different moves and different scenarios
and that poetic and the poetic tragedy
that it gets reduced to one move that
you have to play
and then you're back at it again with
the next move reimagining the world
reimagining the fixed positions and and
and you know again so to me it's it's a
constant sort of uh membrane between the
imaginary and reality that is such a
such a poetic poetic moment i think it's
as a as a cultivator of empathy and a
way to think about uh things with the
world in crisis right now
i honestly can't think of a better way
to help train and develop minds to think
about the possible futures than to think
about how to play chess so totally
unbelievable totally in agreement i
played my game yesterday and uh
i got the candle wax on my fingers i
didn't want to use the tongs i got
singed a couple of times exactly i
managed to win the game fortunately
larry who did you play against and what
was your experience
who was uh both easy game right
obviously a great player and a gentleman
as well which i have to say sort of uh
all of the players are just sort of
terrific
but uh
you know we lit everything up and uh
made two or three moves and i was
checked and so then he sets everything
back up he says okay we've just warmed
up so now we'll begin to play which
how gracious can you be and uh whether
by design or happenstance i was able to
mate him twice before he then sort of uh
gently crushed me like a bug
i think you mean checked him twice
and final word with you glenn first of
all topalov was gracious rex singhfield
wasn't as gracious i would let everybody
know he won his game in four moves he
was brutal to the artist uh i gave him
hell about it
but glenn
where where do you see this going next
and what are your future projects that
we should know about i'm opening a
project in washington dc actually on
friday
which is a large scale monument i made
in collaboration with tommy smith who
was a african-american activist who in
1968 uh won a gold medal and famously
did the uh the black power salute on the
on the podium and um
i've since transposed his arm into uh
building units and i've made a hundred
foot bridge that stands in this large
warehouse but that opens up on on friday
so that's the next project well we wish
you the best of luck with that show
incredible creativity glenn kino larry
lin thanks for joining us
guys back to you
one thing i have to say about the whole
burning boards exhibition was this idea
that chess is a combat and we're trying
to defeat our opponent but with the
boring boards it's a cooperation
because it's sort of like your pieces
are shaped
and you say well you ask one another was
that your knight or your bishop sitting
there and and so it's it's more
cooperation than combat and it was well
yeah i think that's exactly a fun part
of it actually really a beautiful thing
about uh this project is that it's not
all about
winning and that's a funny thing about
chess players when you tell them about
burning boards a lot of them were like
but what are the exact rules like what
happens
it's not a hundred percent cut and dry
there's improv there's working with your
opponent to decide what's going to
happen right like in my situation i say
i won but you say
it was a draw or i lost
where my team was extinguished as i
technated my opponent right right well
keep an eye on that yeah and uh you saw
obviously you saw some beautiful
photographs and uh film film from
spectrum studios here which was i mean
this was just a dream to film and a
dream come true really to see it come to
life at the world chess hall of fame and
indeed and it's just an enjoyable
enjoyable evening all around then we
went and had dinner i'm looking at this
game between
fabiano
cariwana and vessel and topolof as i was
listening to the interview and i'm
sitting there thinking to myself
what is actually going on here
did fabiano lose a knight
what i have in mind is the queen
protects the knight on a4
if black
could push
white's queen away from the protection
of the knight the knight on the rim
would just fall off and so
the move that is attracting my eye
is the move h7
h5 attacking the queen now the queen
again has to keep that connection
with the knight okay so queen f4 okay
and then i'm thinking g7 g5 i think the
problem is you're you've had a little
situation on f7 so queen f3 here
queen f3 here okay i'm thinking that if
queen oh you have so i'm thinking of
queen a4 i have this little
queen takes knight yeah i have this
little bishop g6 tickle okay
so we've sacrificed
a
piece
a knight in this case of course uh to
set up this
lovely little queen f7 check
mate thread seems kind of annoying
doesn't it because if you play
f
if you play f6 here everything's hanging
on g5 as well oh geez well i yeah i
guess i could take an f6 i have to
decide between taking f6 first or just
taking on g5 immediately okay so let me
try oh okay okay good idea so that
limits my options to take in f6 okay
taking on f6 and let's just go down this
so you're trying to just uh stick your
king on g7 well at the moment i'm
thinking that i'm a piece up you have to
prove that this attack is fatal for
black and i'm eyeballing the opportunity
to play queen g4 to bring my queen over
to the defense of my king if i need to
so at the moment this move h5 and maybe
maurice i'm missing something because
the players have played so quickly
what's your take
well there are some tactics here what
really shocked me i researched this
position
was how quickly
fabiano responded to a novelty by his
opponent now we know he's prepared but
this guy looks like no one is shocking
him in any of the games this position
you were talking about king to f8
was played and this is the first time i
found this in any database and he
replied with knight a4
and now this move queen to a5
and very quickly very quickly he just
said no problem i'm just gonna move my
rook to e2 forget all the tactics that
you talked about yes it's like he's seen
it all before he's so well prepared in
every single line well it turns out the
line that you're talking about does not
hurt him h5 queen f4 g5 looks very
powerful but he has his own queen attack
bishop to d2 and this is the problem
he's going to attack that queen and
chase it off the square
obviously if you capture pawn takes
queen he's just going to take the queen
and the structure is not very good for
black in that position queen f3 is not
quite that clear you guys going for this
direct attack with queen takes
excuse me bishop to g6 blacken your
sidestep with the king and then if you
go after this pawn then just sidestep
again and ask you if you have
compensation for the materials certainly
there is some in the position but
probably not necessary again after the
move queen g4 king f8 knight a4 queen a5
just a simple bishop
to d2 sorry just the simple rookie 2 and
that whole attack you talked about with
h5 queen f4 g5 then bishop d2 and this
position is perfectly fine for white
white black has compromised the pawn
structure
fabiano again showing that he's one of
the best prepared players on the planet
and his opponent sitting there now after
rook to e2
has been
there in the tank for a while after this
move it looks like uh again shocked by
his opponent's preparation and indeed it
looks like we have that variation that
you were looking at on the board
i'm looking at uh we have some updates
to that game yeah sir
when you update your board
h5 queen f4 g5 by topolof just and thank
you for clearing the cobwebs they're
my cobwebs uh maurice because the move
bishop d2
uh
wasn't on my radar but bishop d2 is is
absolutely
fine for
black and as you mentioned that in case
of a trait of queens takes takes
black sees his
king side pawn structure compromised the
pawns on f7 and f4 being doubled
nonetheless it appears that this is the
line in fact that both players have gone
for and we are looking at the position
at the moment with both queens under
attack
won by the bishop one by the pawn on g5
and
i don't see the queen slipping back to
c7 but maybe
maybe toppola
is thinking about queen c7 here and
possibly trying to grab i'm an old pong
grubber you know i love grabbing pawns
but this looks like a
whoo you get your finger scorched uh
grabbing a palm i mean
boards right so how are you even so how
are you even picking up the pawn are you
if i play queen g3
well i keep kicking what else h4 yeah
this looks pretty dangerous well i
imagine you would go to e3 right to keep
the pawn on e5 under control and this is
where i was thinking about the move c7
c6 e5 although i don't think you can
always take i'm thinking maybe i could
play queen g4 so that i can meet
um knight takes c5 with uh rook takes e5
and bishop c3 and that's a very nice
skewer against my rook on h8 very well
done
grabbing that rook
parked in the corner
on the other hand this is remarkable
that fabiano sees a new move with queen
a5 and
is just
totally well prepared for it
he mentioned in another game
that
things like that might be potentially
demoralizing to his opponent oh
absolutely you come to the board with a
new idea a novelty and your opponent
responds instantly it's like no you're
not supposed to do that i want to see
you go in the tank
and respect my move
just to finish the line it is
very sharp but i don't see vessel in
playing moves like h4 and h5 and g5 and
allowing the queens to remain on the
board so i do see him as accepting
this inferior
middle game slash ending after a queen
trade
maybe he's thinking that he'll be able
to
toss in f4 f3 in case he needs to gambit
that pawn but a very dangerous
line of play by black here that can't be
fun though you think you got your
opponent you prepared this queen a5 move
and your opponent just responds
instantly yeah that's just
her instantaneous we talked about
fabiano being such a gentleman yesterday
you know playing
he was playing
who actually had a piece here a couple
of years ago which was this marvelous
chess dance right yeah it was really
fantastic and uh she's she's a
russian-american so she has some
background in chess so she knew what she
was doing but at the same time she
forgot which piece was which and caviano
was just like such a gentleman making
sure that uh that the stalemate was
artistically delivered yeah because
basically the idea is you want to keep
this going because it's so much fun it's
such a unique experience
um and i guess fabiano's thought was why
let these candles burn out when there's
still life in them exactly but then on
the other hand he knows when he's over
the board and he has this prepared and
his opponent thought that he might be
surprised
yeah looking out these moves is going to
be a little bit disconcerting for
topolov no doubt in fact he spent 20
minutes on the move h5 i think the
entire time that we were interviewing
glenn and
larry he was probably in the tank about
this move
yeah i mean and it's a crucial critical
moment uh
for the outcome of the opening and it
goes to show how
important it is to seize an advantage
out of the opening these guys are so
good
that any small plus they can get
can be meaningful and at the moment
once more
fabiano
outpreparing his opponent and not even
out preparing his opponent for this game
just he's digging from past preparation
remember earlier in the event that
beautiful wind versus mvl he wasn't
expecting that in that game
so guys at home when you're analyzing an
opening for an opponent and then you get
disappointed and it doesn't come on the
board don't fret you will get another
opportunity if you keep playing chess
you know exactly it's uh it might not
have worked out for the game that you
wanted it to but it will come back no we
do see the move by the way we don't see
that trade of queens and in fact uh
veselan has dropped back with his queen
and he's taken in a huge gamble a big
big risk by advancing his pawns that
were supposed to intended to shield his
king wow this is going to be quite a fun
game
let's see well of course we have many of
you guys chiming in on twitter and
including some of the biggest luminaries
in the chess world so let's take a look
at a couple of the tweets that we've
gotten
from fans of the sing pup
well none other than gary kashbara he
said
any super tournament streak like
carolina's five out of five at the sink
cup is impressive but not all are alike
fabiano hasn't benefited from any real
blunders thank you gary that is a very
good point when indeed a lot of times
you go on a streak and you get a lucky
game like your opponent collapses
or he falls into a opening trap or
something like this but
uh gary is absolutely right all of the
points that
fabiano has garnered thus far he's
earned deserved points and then we also
have a word from our mayor
francis mayor slay who already takes
time to give a shout out to this chess
club which is doing such amazing things
for the city
in a time where there's a lot of
negative news you know
coming out to the opening events always
and he tweeted us that st louis is
hosting the highest rated chess
tournament in the game's history
six of the top ten ranked players in the
world are competing so thanks mayor slay
for always supporting chess i mean this
is really something that st louis can be
proud of whenever i meet somebody from
st louis sometimes in philadelphia where
i live or i go to other places and i
meet st louis and most of them have
heard of the chess club because the
marketing for the club is very good and
i say wow you really should be proud i
mean this is an outstanding thing that
your city has that no other city has
exactly and
it's wonderful to have a really good
friend in in mayor slay he has
been a great supporter and really thank
you very much to the mayor and the
mayor's office for all of their
supportive words and assistance uh
during all of the events u.s
championships i've always seen the mayor
and representatives come so it's really
really great to have that kind of
political support
all right
so after g5 queen c7 finally fabiana
slowed down or pardon me he hasn't he
indeed has made his move and he did play
the move queen g3
okay uncovering an attack against the
pawn on g5 this is what you had wanted
to do jen keep that attack
and
also keep the pawn on e5 protected our
variation had continued h4
you had
shown a very nice gear
after queen g4 again
just simply wanting to capture this pawn
i took your pawn because i'm a
pawn grubber
you had taken my knight which looks very
good and you uh obscured the rook
the line that i had played continued was
queen f4
and then after what i thought would be a
trait of queens you would grab my rook
so at the moment black is material ahead
but look at that bishop on h8 no no no
not yet we were up abuse uh white is
mature why does material have but after
you're saying after f6 they're
threatening to play king to g8 right
sorry now i have the unusual move bishop
h7
king g8 but that looks quite that looks
quite awkward to say the least well so i
don't know if this uh variation is
forced or not
but
it's still
anybody's game at the moment i was
thinking that you're right you could go
bishop h7 super awkward though i mean it
feels like you should be able to play
like king of seven and bishop somewhere
but right i mean maybe not because i do
have the knight b6 idea right you could
go maybe knight b6 and just simply
uh
go after and snap on this pawn and for
instance what i was saying is that a
bishop h7 in a position like this you
just have king f7 right and then the
bishop gets trapped in precisely so
precisely so correct exactly the bishop
remains
stuck on the h8 square now that whole
variation is not by any means forcing
but it's an interesting one maurice
yeah i think maurice has something for
us in another opening that surprised us
today
a surprising opening between carl
between carlson
and maxime rasheela grav
the thing is that carlson has been on
the black side of this position a few
times he used to play it back when he
was a wee babe back in 2006
eight years ago and he got a draw the
last game we see with him at against
this piano he got a draw in this line
but his opponent played the popular move
castles when with white so imagine
carlson had the black pieces in that
game but his opponent played the
actually far more popular castles the
move castles in this position here is 10
times more popular than the move that
carlson chose which is f3
it had it was played
2244 times that is castles over 2000
times and only
227 times the move f3 in the database
and when f3 was played the most popular
move after that was d7 d6 or d7 d5 the
third most popular one-tenth as popular
is the most popular move is e6 so these
guys are digging down deep into opening
theory to play these moves and this move
by mvl not a common move and car
not a common move against an uncommon
play in f3 by the way so carlson you can
see why he's stopping to think what does
this guy have planned maybe i played an
offbeat move and he's quickly responded
with another offbeat move himself so
rich openings to start this round of the
singfield cup guys
thank you maurice yeah let's take a look
at the history between these two players
you know i not normally expecting magnus
to be playing an open sicilian but if
you go back to this 2005 match that
carlson played against maxine bossier
lagrange both those games were sicilians
so it's kind of uh what a it's a prime
it's a hearkening box a little bit
nostalgia right well at the same time
you know that was the same year that
i've been kind of burning boards first
premiered in new york wow wow
um it it often happens when two players
sit down and both have a very stubborn
view about a certain variation that they
repeat it constantly and we've seen this
a lot in world championship matches for
example gary was playing grunfeld
against karpov and that was a
his favorite defense so it seems like
both players have
a favored uh sicilian as black and
they've been playing it a lot
um now meanwhile we have the game
nakamura aronian in which uh we
mentioned that nakamura's choice um
hasn't been doing amazingly here lately
theoretically in fact uh
the brilliant theoretician as we can see
fab fabuano um fabiano carrana actually
had a
game in the olympiad as black where he
drew very comfortably against shiraz in
this line exactly
and this variation because if you look
at the pawn structure the all
all the pawns
are symmetrical seven versus seven the
only open
pardon me
the only open file in the position is
the e file and the old soviet school
they would refer to such open files
as the chopping block both players would
try to contest with their rooks and
a lot of wood gets chopped on the
e-file although this is a little bit
unusual and that minor pieces aren't out
yet right and there have been some
players who tried to stick the bishop on
d3 to go for like a quick caveman attack
but
not at this level no
so the idea what what white is trying to
achieve is a is the advantage of winning
the two bishops and with his last move
knight c3 what uh icaru wants to do is
bring his knight to the center of the
board and hunt down this dark squared
bishop on e7 to maintain that small
advantage to show hey i've got something
for this opening precisely so the move
knight d6 to e8 is popular black steps
back with his knight to
begin to open up this bishop on c8 by
advancing his d-pawn knight d5 as
mentioned going after this bishop
uh the bishop returns the favor it's
it's being attacked it returns a favor
by attacking white's rook on e5 the rook
drops back to e2 so the idea of the rook
dropping back to e2 as opposed to e1
white has sometimes in mind the idea of
queen e1 knight e7 check kind of like a
mini allocated gun right exactly and
captured stun gun i like that uh going
after this bishop on c8
the game continued c6 knight dropped
back bishop dropped back another kind of
gun is when you have two rooks and a
queen behind it exactly queen e1 bishop
f6 so all of these moves were played
and i believe this has
been seen before this exact play so
white has achieved what he wants which
is well he has two bishops against a
bishop and knight combination however
we saw this in the first sink field cup
in 2013 there was a game between
hikaru nakamura white
magnus carlson black and magnus achieved
a comfortable draw in that game but you
might recall that in that game magnus
did something quite unusual he actually
advanced his pawn from f7 to f5
and let's see just to get caught up with
the players the move g3 by the way opens
up a possibility of bishop h3 sure our
bishop on f1 is blocked by a rick and e2
so right so queen d7 stopping the bishop
from activating
d2d3
knight c7 and again black is looking to
bring his rook to e8
uh and try to chop
wood on e2 and win control of the
e file at the moment this bishop on f6
bears down on that pawn on b2 so i would
suspect that hikaru might play a move
like c2 c3
and no in order to be able to develop
his bishop that's right and no doubt
about it i'd rather be white but
what do you think do you think nakamura
is going to be able to make anything of
this certainly the teamist of the games
that we have today right we've got
two
exciting sicilians and then we've got
this where
the pawn structure is totally
symmetrical and nakamura's got that that
little two bishop edge right and it just
feels to me that it's not going to be
enough to get anything significant
external weaknesses you do love the true
bishops of course you don't know how to
really coordinate them here well in this
particular position because
blacks
where is black wheat where
are the black pawn weaknesses residing
it's very hard to see so i don't see too
much coming out of this game but on the
other hand we have two others
squeeze yeah you got two other thrillers
and maybe this one will get hot later
maurice has something for us and one of
our sicilians yes
jen and yaz it looks as though fabiano
had to sacrifice and he seems to still
be within his preparation because he's
still playing very quickly in this
position topalov did play the move h4
attacking the queen and he played the
move qui g4 did caruana he had to play
this move it looks like because queen e3
just trying to be passive holding on to
this pawn would have been met by the
move c5 and suddenly their attacks on
his pawn or his queen that are going to
mess with his position for example if he
played the move c3 here believe it or
not in order to stop the move d4 this
move
h3 was the move to really discombobulate
the white position if you capture this
pawn on h3 suddenly bishop to b7 and
this bishop cuts a beautiful figure
along the long diagonal these variations
are not good for white after c5 if we
jump back to that position if c4
uh certainly after c4 d4 is what black
wants to do anyway and now queen e4
would be crazy because this bishop comes
with tempo attacking the white queen on
the long diagonal forcing white to
donate the pawn but with no tactical
opportunities so black would have just
pushed the pawn on the bishop out for no
reason which is why we go back to the
position after h4 we see that queen to g
was played
looking for the line you mentioned with
knight takes e4 but te paulov went into
a deep thing before he played this move
seeing his pawn hanging in his rook in
trouble he's introduced the wrinkle rook
to g8 and now it is caruana's turn to
give pause so this game is wild and
crazy somebody's winning this one is my
bet
who is it going to be topalov who's been
surging or caruana who's been perfect
well let's see him right there it's deep
in thought in what is a very exciting
game of round six at the sinkfield cup
guys thanks maurice and i wonder if
fabiano carrano might have gotten some
new ideas
about this from his own game he actually
played this variation as black
in the olympiad it was a draw and he
played the move king f8 as well exactly
so
same variation and then instead of his
12th move knight a4 white played queenie
two instead
so still fresh in his mind and that game
was pointed out by international master
robert reese who is thank you is your
buddy right absolutely yeah wonderful
shout out hi
it's great to hear from all of these uh
grand masters and international masters
who are watching our coverage it's very
flattering yeah king f8
uh played by fabio and cariwanna just in
tromso right right in tromso just the
the month of august so this is a very
topical variation suddenly and this move
rook g8
um as marie saying just leaving it up to
white to answer a crucial question how
do you want to defend the pawn on e5
i'm assuming rook
a1 to e1
um is a reasonable move perhaps not the
only move but rook a1 e1 and now we
understand what black wants to do
with the move c5
in order to open up his bishop and
maurice was mentioning sometimes that
move h3 h2h3 can be more than
nettlesome because it could get at black
white's king and open up some light
squares
on the other hand
this
position just has that feel that black
is going too far he's taking too many
risks you don't like having your king on
f8 and your pawn
it doesn't
at all the harmony between the pieces
yeah
and i'm just wondering if why can't
sa a move like f2 f4 one day
maybe in combination with queen h5 and
black's king could come under heavy
pressure let me just put the move i want
to show i mean to be fair black is is
will just by the choice of opening is
willing to suffer a little bit
well he may suffer a lot a bit
to be uh to be clear fabiano played so
quickly but it does seem like he's
stopping to think a little bit after
rook to g8 so he hasn't banged down his
move right i was just putting some moves
on the board there jen rook e1 defending
the pawn c5 c3
just so that i can
drop back with the bishop if i necessary
bishop b7
and let's imagine a move like queen h5
here i know this is getting sharp
but i do have this idea of f 2
f 4 in mind trying to blow up
trying to blow up
the squares around black's king
and it's
very very double-edged
double edged for one side for both sides
because there are you know maurice had
mentioned that if you can get that queen
and bishop battery
you could be looking very pretty
because you're attacking a4 and g2
simultaneously so there's tactics that
white has to watch out for but the
reason why i was trying to get in f2 f4
is that in that case i'll be defending
g2 as well as attacking g5 and maybe
opening up an avenue of bishop h6 so
a very dangerous position for black
indeed exactly double edged maybe for
both sides because opening up the g file
well
that also opens up a counter attack for
black as well against the g2 pawn so
lots of sharp things happening in that
game shall we switch to the game between
magnus carlsen for a moment yeah
because this
accelerated dragon
position
really